This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Not long ago, I found myself in a subterranean labyrinth below the streets of Washington, DC. I'd come and search of clues. So here we are in Deck 50 in the Stacks of the Library of Congress. I'm opening a door that's marked Door 20. My guide is a tall, shaggy man named Steve Winick. He looks a lot like Hagrid from Harry Potter, which seems about right for somebody with
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔。不久前，我在华盛顿特区街道下方的地下迷宫中，寻找着线索。我们现在身处国会图书馆书库的第50区。我正在打开一扇标着“20号门”的门。我的向导是一个高大、头发蓬乱的男人，名叫史蒂夫·维尼克。他看起来很像《哈利·波特》里的海格，对于一个拥有……的人来说，这似乎再合适不过了
a title of folklorist. Steve has already led me through a maze of low-ceiling stacks across a small bridge and into a tiny elevator where the flow numbers go up as we go down. But now we've arrived. In here, we find row upon row of collection boxes on the shelves, and I'm looking for this collection, which is numbered AFC 1979-008. Steve pulls from the shelf a cardboard box. Nobody's really used this collection very much, so it's simply, you know, been there waiting
民俗学者头衔的人。史蒂夫已经带我穿过了一片低矮书库的迷宫，穿过一座小桥，进了一个小电梯，在那里，我们往下走时，楼层数字却在上升。但现在我们到了。在这里，我们看到书架上一排又一排的藏品盒，而我在寻找这个编号为 AFC 1979-008 的藏品。史蒂夫从书架上抽出一个纸板箱。基本上没有人用过这个藏品，所以它只是，你知道的，一直在那儿等着
for you, really. The author of this collection is Richard Riley Shepard, a small time crook and con man who died in 2009. I've been tracking Riley Shepard for a few months. My assumption is that there's nothing of significance in the box. But I'm about to discover that the story I thought I was reporting is not the story I am reporting. The story that is about one fold before me is a story of obsession. one fall before me is a story of obsession. It's power, it's beauty, and it's costs. This week on Hidden Brain, we explore the peculiar tale of Riley Shepard, a musician and writer who spent decades on a single grand project. Whether that project was a great quest or a great folly, that is for you to decide.
你，真的。这个藏品的作者是理查德·莱利·谢帕德（Richard Riley Shepard），一个在2009年去世的小偷和骗子。我追踪莱利·谢帕德已经几个月了。我的假设是，这个箱子里没有什么重要的东西。但我即将发现，我以为我在报道的故事，并不是我正在报道的故事。我面前摊开的这个故事，是一个关于痴迷的故事。我面前摊开的这个故事，是一个关于痴迷的故事。它是力量，是美丽，也是它的代价。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们将探讨莱利·谢帕德这个奇特的故事，他是一位音乐家和作家，将几十年的时间倾注在一个宏大的单一项目上。至于这个项目是一次伟大的探索还是一场巨大的愚蠢，这由你来决定。
He was a genius, I think. He just was a compulsive liar. Quite a master. He was getting out of town before he was being tarting together. I haven't got time for that. I gotta get this done. They all hate you, my gun. I said, fuck time for that. I gotta get this done. They are all hating my gun. I should forgive them. Albert Riley, Joe Graham, Richard. I stumbled onto the story as I was contemplating an episode not about obsession, but about fallen
我认为他是个天才。他只是个强迫性说谎者。相当厉害的大师。他在快要被人用柏油和羽毛惩罚之前溜出了城。我没时间理会那个。我得把这个搞定。他们都恨你，我的枪。我说，他妈的没时间理会那个。我得把这个搞定。他们都在恨我的枪。我应该原谅他们。阿尔伯特·莱利、乔·格雷厄姆、理查德。我偶然发现这个故事时，正在构思一集关于陨落……而不是痴迷的节目
heroes. I'd asked hidden brain listeners to share examples from their own lives. One of the messages, I hope I did this right, was from Stasha Shepard Silverman. She said her fallen hero was her dad, Riley Shepard, whom she still loved. I want to say that I had a great relationship with my father. He was totally cool in many ways and a great cook. When we talk, Stasha tells me that as a young girl, she idolized her dad.
英雄。我曾请《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享他们自己生活中的例子。其中一条信息，希望我没弄错，来自斯塔莎·谢帕德·西尔弗曼（Stasha Shepard Silverman）。她说她心目中的陨落英雄是她的父亲莱利·谢帕德，她至今仍深爱着他。我想说的是，我和父亲的关系非常好。他在很多方面都很酷，而且是个很棒的厨师。当我们交谈时，斯塔莎告诉我，作为一个小女孩，她将父亲视为偶像。
She has memories of those days that feel like tiny, sparkling gems. My earliest memory of my dad is sitting on his lap and him smoking his cigar, and he would make cigar smoke rings for me. Stasha would watch them, transfixed, as they rose in the air before her. I thought the smoke rings were magical.
她对那段日子的记忆就像一颗颗细小、闪烁的宝石。我对爸爸最早的记忆是坐在他的大腿上，他抽着雪茄，会为我吐出雪茄烟圈。斯塔莎会出神地看着它们，看着它们在她面前升入空中。我觉得烟圈太神奇了。
There was a lot that was magical for Stasha back then. She still remembers their little apartment in Hollywood, with the Symees cat and the cat hair and the hardwood floors. She remembers how much she loved that her dad was around all the time. He didn't have a regular job and he would sit in the middle of the living room usually, wherever we lived, and he would type. So he was working on things. He was working on, I didn't know what,
对那时的斯塔莎来说，有很多事情都是神奇的好吗。她仍然记得他们在好莱坞的小公寓，里面有暹罗猫、猫毛和硬木地板。她记得她多么喜欢爸爸一直陪在身边。他没有固定工作，通常会坐在客厅的正中央，无论我们住在哪里，他都会打字。所以他一直在忙着做事情。他在忙着，我不知道是什么，
but I would sit under his desk sometimes while he typed away and we would talk in between the pages and he would tell me things about show business. They were in their own little bubble. Riley in his late 50s and his little daughter. Typing, talking, just being together. Sometimes if Riley had a little daughter, typing, talking, just being together. Sometimes, if Riley had a little money, he'd take Starshire out to eat at their favorite Hollywood hotspot,
但我有时会坐在他的书桌底下，听着他噼里啪啦地打字，我们在字里行间交谈，他会跟我讲一些关于娱乐圈的事情。他们生活在自己小小的泡沫里。快60岁的莱利和他的小女儿。打字、聊天，只是在一起。有时，如果莱利手头有一点钱，他会带斯塔莎去他们最喜欢的好莱坞热门地点吃饭，
a restaurant called the Brown Derby. It was a place where Riley could drop shoulders with famous people, charm them with his warm southern accent, and impress his daughter on their way home. You know, the Hollywood stars were all around us. We could walk up the street and my father would tell me about movie stars when we walked. He seemed to know everything. Stasha was certain that her dad was something of a star himself. Sometimes he tell her about his musical career as a successful promoter, singer and songwriter. Occasionally, he might even sing
一家名为“棕色德比”的餐厅。这是一个莱利可以与名人肩并肩、用他温暖的南方口音迷倒他们、并在回家路上给女儿留下深刻印象的地方。你知道，好莱坞明星到处都是。我们可以走在街上，我父亲会在我们散步时给我讲电影明星的事。他似乎无所不知。斯塔莎确信她的父亲本身就是某种明星。有时他会告诉她自己作为一名成功的推广人、歌手和词曲作家的音乐生涯。偶尔，他甚至会唱
the song, his song. He told me and he told everyone that he wrote the song Blue Christmas. He told me and he told everyone that he wrote the song Blue Christmas. It wasn't true. Billy Hayes and Jay Johnson wrote Blue Christmas. The person who made it famous? Elvis. If Riley had written Blue Christmas, money might not have been so tight for the family. I was told constantly that we were artists and that there were artists and there were ordinary people and we were artists. Stascha eventually learned about her dad's most important artistic endeavor, not a song, but a writing project.
那首歌，他写的歌。他告诉我，也告诉所有人，他写了那首歌《蓝色圣诞节》。他告诉我，也告诉所有人，他写了那首歌《蓝色圣诞节》。这不是真的。比利·海斯（Billy Hayes）和杰伊·约翰逊（Jay Johnson）写了《蓝色圣诞节》。让它成名的人是谁？猫王。如果莱利写了《蓝色圣诞节》，家里的日子也许就不会那么紧巴了。我经常被告知我们是艺术家，世上有艺术家，也有普通人，而我们是艺术家。斯塔莎最终了解到了她父亲最重要的艺术努力，不是一首歌，而是一个写作项目。
The encyclopedia of folk music. And that was supposedly his life's work. And it was vast. I mean, there were boxes there, huge boxes of volumes of indexes and things he was working on in books. To fund its creation, Riley solicited money from investors, some of whom he convinced to pour thousands of dollars into the project. Sometimes investors and bill collectors would call to ask when they were going to get paid. He used to get on the phone with all kinds of people and say,
《民间音乐百科全书》。这据说是他一生的心血。而且工程浩大。我的意思是，那里有箱子，装满索引卷宗和其他他在书里研究的东西的巨大箱子。为了资助它的创作，莱利向投资者募集资金，其中一些人被他说服向该项目投入了数千美元。有时，投资者和催收员会打电话询问他们什么时候能拿到钱。他过去常常和各种各样的人通电话，然后说：
you didn't get the check. What? The post office, he would constantly rail against the post office. So as a little girl, I also became very militant against the post office. I also would rail against the post office. I also would rail against the post office. And if I had a pen pal or a friend that I was writing a letter to, I'd always write on the outside of the envelope,
你没收到支票吗？什么？邮局，他经常怒气冲冲地斥责邮局。所以作为一个小女孩，我对邮局也变得非常激进。我也会怒斥邮局。我也会怒斥邮局。如果我有笔友或朋友要写信，我总会在信封外面写上：
you better deliver this letter. You know, I was like enraged with the post office that they wouldn't deliver letters because I just thought they're constantly throwing my dad under the bus and not mailing his checks. For many children, there is a moment when a curtain pulls back and parents are revealed for who they are, in perfect beings, with flaws and failings. But for Starscher, the father she saw when the curtain opened, was hard to recognize.
你最好把这封信送到。你知道的，我对邮局不肯送信感到非常愤怒，因为我只是觉得他们一直在背后捅我父亲的刀子，不把他的支票寄出去。对许多孩子来说，都会有一个时刻，幕布拉开，父母的真面目显露出来——他们是不完美的人，有着缺点和过失。但对斯塔莎来说，当幕布拉开时她看到的父亲，却很难辨认。
It happened one day when she was 12, hanging out at home. And the phone rang. So I picked it up, I said hello. The caller demanded to speak to her dad. Starscher said he was out. His voice was shaking, and I could tell he was elderly. And he just sounded like a mean old man to me. He scared me.
这件事发生在她12岁那年的一天，当时她正独自在家闲逛。电话响了。于是我接了起来，说了声你好。打电话的人要求找她爸爸。斯塔莎说他不在。他的声音在颤抖，我能听出他年纪很大了。在我听来，他就像个刻薄的老头。他吓到我了。
And he told me that my father took his life savings. The phone is in my ear, and he's saying, your father's a crook. Did you know that? Your father is a crook. In 1946, Riley Shepard released a cover of the hit song, Atomic Power. It was inspired by the bombings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki. All this world is at a tremble with its strength and mighty power. They're sending up to heaven to get the brimstone fire. Riley was a rising talent.
他告诉我，我父亲拿走了他的毕生积蓄。电话紧贴着我的耳朵，他说：“你父亲是个骗子。你知道吗？你父亲是个骗子。”1946年，莱利·谢帕德发行了一首热门歌曲《原子力量》的翻唱版。这首歌的灵感来自于广岛和长崎的原子弹爆炸。整个世界都在为其力量和强大威力而颤抖。他们正把硫磺火送上天堂。莱利曾是一个崭露头角的天才。
He had dark, good looks, a soft southern twang, and the guitar skills to make a go of it. He signed with various labels. He seemed headed somewhere. But Riley Shepard never achieved Stardom. Instead, his life took a series of detours. Music historian Kevin Coffey tracked Riley down about a decade ago. Riley at the time was 89.
他有着英俊的黑发、柔和的南方口音，以及玩转这一切的吉他技巧。他与各大厂牌签约。他似乎前途无量。但莱利·谢帕德从未达到过明星的高度。相反，他的人生经历了一系列曲折。音乐史学家凯文·科菲（Kevin Coffey）在大约十年前找到了莱利。当时的莱利已经89岁了。
He would die a year later. Kevin was interested in preserving the stories of all-time country-western performers. He thought Riley might be worth profiling. He played steel in one of your records. The conversation they had over a crackly phone line was friendly and nostalgic and full of insider names most people wouldn't recognize. And his lawyer's wife was played piano, really hard, really? Yeah. Gradually Kevin pieced together Riley's backstory.
他一年后去世了。凯文对保存所有时代的乡村音乐表演者的故事很感兴趣。他认为莱利可能值得为其做个生平简介。他在你的一张唱片里弹过钢吉他。他们在嘶嘶作响的电话线两端的谈话友好而怀旧，充满了大多数人认不出的大人物的名字。他律师的妻子弹过钢琴，真的很厉害，真的吗？是的。凯文渐渐拼凑出了莱利的背景故事。
Richard Riley Shepherd was born on a farm near Wilmington, North Carolina in 1918. He dropped out of school in the 5th grade and decided to try his luck at singing. It was a heady time for music in the region, groups like the Maynors Mountainears were popularizing what was then called Hilbilly Music. I'm not my home, I'm just a place in truth. Lately I stand my home, I'll find beyond the blues. Burmini friends who helped me and has gone before, and I can't be there home in this world anymore. Riley started out playing songs in minstrel shows. Soon he told Kevin he was getting gigs with hillbilly groups like the Dixie Reelers. By the early 1940s, Riley had moved to Chicago.
理查德·莱利·谢帕德于1918年出生在北卡罗来纳州威尔明顿附近的一个农场。他在5年级时辍学，决定去碰碰运气唱歌。对于该地区的音乐来说，那是一个令人兴奋的时期，“梅诺斯山地人”（Maynors Mountainears）等乐队正在推广当时被称为山地乡村音乐的曲风。我不在我的家，我只是真理中的一个地方。最近我坚守家园，我会在悲伤之外找到它。无数帮助过我、已经离去的朋友，我再也不能回到这个世界的家了。莱利最初是在杂耍秀中弹唱歌曲。不久，他告诉凯文，他开始在诸如“迪克西卷轴者”（Dixie Reelers）这样的山地乐队里接活。到20世纪40年代初，莱利已经搬到了芝加哥。
He toured with other hillbilly musicians and did comedy and acting work. He also began cultivating his image as a cowboy crooner. As he created this new persona, he gave himself a catchy moniker, the cowboy philosopher. To top off his fancy new title of philosopher, Riley grew a dashing moustache and began scheming up fresh ways to get into the spotlight. The cosmopolitan church presents Dr. Richard Riley Shepard, Ph.D.D.D. This is Tasha again. A few years ago, she found one of the old flyers that advertised her dad's lectures.
他与其他山地音乐家一起巡演，并从事喜剧和表演工作。他还开始打造自己作为牛仔歌手的形象。在创造这个新的人设时，他给自己起了一个引人注目的绰号——牛仔哲学家。为了给自己的这个花哨新头衔增光添彩，莱利留起了时髦的胡子，并开始策划新的方式来吸引聚光灯。大都会教堂呈献理查德·莱利·谢帕德博士。这是斯塔莎。几年前，她找到了宣传她父亲讲座的一张旧传单。
Dr. Richard Riley Shepard, author, historian, world traveler, philosopher. In a series of educational lectures. The world traveler and philosopher was prepared to discuss a variety of important topics. Saturday, October 10, God, man, of important topics. Even as he sought to make a name for himself with his educational lectures, Riley was still churning out songs at a frenzied pace, often releasing a new record every month. But Kevin says Rylee wasn't reliable. He'd signed with one record label, and while his contract was still in force, he'd sign with another.
理查德·莱利·谢帕德博士，作家、历史学家、世界旅行家、哲学家。在一系列教育讲座中。这位世界旅行家兼哲学家准备讨论各种重要话题。10月10日星期六，上帝、人类，重要话题。正当他试图通过教育讲座让自己名声大噪时，莱利仍然以疯狂的速度源源不断地创作歌曲，通常每个月都会发行一张新唱片。但凯文说莱利并不靠谱。他与一家唱片公司签约，而在合同依然有效的情况下，他又会与另一家签约。
He'd often use different stage names or pseudonyms with different labels. For a time, Riley was able to make it all work, in part because he did have a little star power. He'd done well with atomic power and later had another catchy tune titled Cowboy. I was looking for a window and I saw a thing called, Hall's closing,. Big sign. And then, our diction came in. This was our diction, Paul. That sounded okay. This was how Riley operated. He played fast and loose. He also worked as an agent, getting music labels to sign new artists.
他在不同的厂牌通常会使用不同的艺名或化名。有一段时间，莱利把这一切都处理得很好，部分原因是他确实有一点明星光环。他在《原子力量》上做得很好，后来又推出了另一首朗朗上口的曲子《牛仔》。我正在寻找一扇窗户，我看到一个叫“霍尔倒闭”的东西。大招牌。然后，我们的发音进来了。这就是我们的发音，保罗。听起来还行。这就是莱利的运作方式。他做事草率且不守规矩。他还当过经纪人，拉拢音乐厂牌签下新艺术家。
You see, I tell him, what do you think a publisher is? He's just a businessman. He wouldn't know a hit song to crawl out from under his desk and beat him under the lake. He sold songs to these executives with a combination of bluster and hype. This role allowed Riley to capitalize on one of his greatest strengths. He was a born salesman. He once boasted that he could have started his own religion. You're here as red, your eyes are blue, that's what my horse and dog for you. Recording by him on a small label, and he brought it to me, and I said,
你看，我告诉他，你觉得出版商是什么？他只是个商人。就算一首热门单曲从他的办公桌底下爬出来敲打他的膝盖，他都不认识。他凭借浮夸和炒作的组合，把歌曲卖给这些高管。这个角色让莱利得以充分利用他最大的优势之一。他是个天生的推销员。他曾吹嘘说自己本可以创立一个属于他自己的宗教。你这里的头发是红的，你的眼睛是蓝的，这就是我的马和狗对你的意义。他在一个小厂牌上录制的唱片，他把它拿给我，我说：
if you do want to tell you, you'll make a lot of money. And he did. He did it too. I got him $7,000 in advance, and $7 cents a copy. It's the biggest money I've ever paid for avillage all the time, in those days. Riley was also a hustler in his personal life, where the consequences of his actions were more serious. Marion Kiminik knows this well.
如果你真的想告诉大家，你会赚很多钱的。他确实做到了。他真的做到了。我帮他拿到了7000美元的预付款，还有每卖出一本7美分的分成。这是我在那个时代为整个村庄付过的最大一笔钱。莱利在个人生活中也是一个投机取巧的人，在那里他的行为后果更为严重。玛丽安·基米尼克（Marion Kiminik）对此深有体会。
She was adopted at birth. As an adult, she searched for and found her biological mother. From her, Marion learned that her father was Riley Shepard. Marion's mother had met him while working as an actress in Chicago. And she said he was very charming, very good looking. He played the guitar and he sang. And I guess she was kind of smitten with him and... She got pregnant. That, she told Marion, wasn't supposed to happen. He told her he was sterile. And for what I understand, he told every woman he was with that he was sterile. The world will never know the reason, the reason why I said we're through. Whatever he'd achieved in the music industry, it was all winding down by the early 1960s. Then, Riley had picked up and moved on to the West Coast.
她是在出生时被收养的。成年后，她寻找并找到了自己的亲生母亲。从母亲那里，玛丽安得知她的父亲是莱利·谢帕德。玛丽安的母亲在芝加哥做演员时认识了他。她说他非常迷人、非常英俊。他会弹吉他和唱歌。我想她当时有点迷恋他……她怀孕了。她告诉玛丽安，这是不应该发生的事。他告诉她自己没有生育能力。据我所知，他对跟他在一起的每个女人都说自己没有生育能力。世人永远不会知道原因，我宣告我们结束的原因。无论他在音乐界取得过什么成就，到20世纪60年代初都已经在走下坡路了。随后，莱利收拾行囊搬到了西海岸。
He first went to Oregon and then to California. He told Kevin he gave up the music business, so he could turn his attention to a new project, an encyclopedia of folk music. But Kevin, things years of lying and cheating and breaking contracts had simply caught up with him. He made it sound like he did these moves for different purposes. I think you usually he was getting out of town before he was being tartan-fethered. It's perhaps fitting that the place Riley landed for the next chapter of his life was Hollywood.
他先去了俄勒冈州，然后去了加利福尼亚州。他告诉凯文，他放弃了音乐事业，以便将注意力转向一个新项目——一本民间音乐百科全书。但凯文认为，多年的撒谎、欺骗和撕毁合同的行为终于让他尝到了苦果。他把这些搬迁说成是为了不同的目的。我认为通常是因为他在快要被人用柏油和羽毛惩罚之前赶紧溜之大吉。莱利为他人生的下一篇章落脚的地方是好莱坞，这或许再合适不过了。
Tinseltown was shiny and bright and full of the kind of transformative stories that Riley loved. He arrived there with his common law wife and young daughter, Stascha. For a while he thrived in his new role as Riley Shepard, Family Man. But like most things in Riley's life, it didn't last. Your father is a crook. After all these years, Stasha still fixates on the memory of that old man's telephone call. Stasha says it was a turning point in her relationship with her father.
浮华世界光鲜亮丽，充满着莱利所喜爱的那些充满戏剧性转变的故事。他带着事实上的妻子和幼小的女儿斯塔莎来到了那里。有一段时间，他在自己作为“莱利·谢帕德，好男人”的新角色中过得很滋润。但就像莱利生活中的大多数事情一样，这并没有持续多久。你父亲是个骗子。多年后，斯塔莎仍然对那个老头的电话记忆犹新。斯塔莎说那是她与父亲关系的一个转折点。
That night, she confronted him. Right when he walked in the door, I was like, you know, screaming at him, you're a crook, you're a crook, you're a crook. And he looked at me like he turned white and he was shocked. And he argued, we argued, we fought. I don't remember the exact words, but I remember he stormed out and he went out to his car and he sat there and smoked and he didn't come back inside for a long time. He would just, that's what he would do and he was mad, he would go out and he was
那天晚上，她和他当面对质。就在他走进门的那一刻，我简直就像是在对他尖叫：你是个骗子，你是个骗子，你是个骗子。他看着我，脸色苍白，震惊不已。他争辩着，我们争辩着，我们吵架了。我不记得具体说了什么话，但我记得他气冲冲地冲了出去，走到他的车里坐下抽烟，好长时间都没有进屋。他总是这样，那就是他的作风，当他生气时，他就会出去
car and pout. But the next morning, Riley did what came naturally to him. He turned on the charm. He tried to smooth things over. He made stasha pancakes. He told her the Encyclopedia was going to make a lot of money and that his investors would get paid. Stascha wanted to believe him.
在车里生闷气。但第二天早上，莱利做出了对他来说最自然的事。他开启了魅力攻势。他试图把事情平息下来。他给斯塔莎做了煎饼。他告诉她，那部百科全书会赚很多钱，他的投资者也会拿到钱。斯塔莎想要相信他。
Well, you know, I loved my dad and he was very apologetic and sweet and you want to believe your parents. And also he was very good at convincing. Stasha didn't know how much money her dad owed, but she got the sense he was constantly evading creditors. She tells one story of calling home to get a ride. And when my dad picked up the phone, he was pretending to be a Chinese man. He was pretending to be, use this accent that, like from breakfast at Tiffany's, that horrible, you know,
嗯，你知道的，我爱我爸爸，他非常抱歉而且很讨人喜欢，你会想要去相信你的父母。而且他非常善于说服别人。斯塔莎不知道她父亲欠了多少钱，但她隐约觉得他在不断地逃避债主。她讲了一个故事，说自己打电话回家想让家里人开车接她。当她爸爸接起电话时，他假装是一个中国男人。他假装在用一种……就像《蒂凡尼的早餐》里那种可怕的口音，你知道的，
was that Mickey Rooney? Anyway, terrible. But I knew it was him, you know your father's voice. I'm like, dad, and he was like, hung up on me. Riley took every shortcut he could to make a buck. For a time, he wrote porn under the pseudonym Zachary Quill. One of his books, Glowing Heat. Stascha says her mother told her that Riley had worked out of formula. She said, oh, well, dad used to get all these cheap novels and then he would write porn
那是米奇·鲁尼吗？不管怎样，糟透了。但我知道那就是他，你总认得你父亲的声音。我说：“爸爸”，然后他就挂了我电话。为了赚钱，莱利可谓不择手段。有一段时间，他以“扎卡里·奎尔”（Zachary Quill）的化名撰写色情小说。他的其中一本书叫《炽热》（Glowing Heat）。斯塔莎说她母亲告诉她，莱利摸索出了一套公式。她说，哦，好吧，爸爸以前会收集所有这些廉价小说，然后他会写色情
scenes and he would have typists insert the porn scenes in these crappy novels and resell them. This was Tasha's life. Things were always off-kilter, confusing. She remembers another time when they had to flee their house before the landlord came, probably because Riley hadn't paid the rent. We got in this rickety old truck with all our stuff jammed in it. And my father's encyclopedia of folk music was in there very carefully packed. Those were the biggest boxes that we took.
场景，并让打字员把这些色情场景插入到这些烂小说里，然后再转卖出去。这就是斯塔莎的生活。事情总是乱七八糟、令人困惑。她记得还有一次，他们不得不在房东来之前逃离他们的房子，很可能是因为莱利没有付房租。我们坐进这辆破旧的老卡车里，塞满了我们所有的东西。我父亲的那部民间音乐百科全书就放在里面，包装得非常仔细。那是我们带走的最大的箱子。
And all our other stuff was just kind of strewn in this truck. And it wasn't very well packed. And when we were driving down the highway, I remember this. It was so weird. People were pointing at us and trying to get our attention and we were like, I mean, I remember my mother being like, why are they waving at us? And then realizing, oh, our stuff is flying out.
而我们其他的所有东西都只是乱七八糟地散落在卡车里。而且打包得并不好。当我们沿着高速公路开车时，我记得这个。太奇怪了。人们指着我们，试图引起我们的注意，而我们却像……我的意思是，我记得我母亲当时说：“他们为什么在向我们挥手？”然后才意识到，哦，我们的东西正在飞出去。
Like our slim belongings that we had paired down from selling almost everything else, those things were flying out, not the encyclopedia folk music, but my clothes and what few things. By the late 1970s, the family had settled in Portoville, California, a town on the western edge of the Sierra Nevada mountains. Riley spent his days working on his encyclopedia
就像我们卖掉几乎所有东西后精简下来的微薄财产，那些东西正在飞出去，飞出去的不是那部民间音乐百科全书，而是我的衣服和仅有的一点东西。到20世纪70年代末，一家人定居在加利福尼亚州的波特维尔，这是一座位于内华达山脉西麓的小镇。莱利每天都在埋头编写他的百科全书
and to Stascha's mind, swindling everyone he could. It all ended when Stastasha was 18. That year, 1983, Riley Shepard did what he had done many times before. He disappeared. He told my mother who he had been with for whatever 23 years that he was taking a short trip to Los Angeles. But when she woke up in the morning she realized that he had taken way more than what you would need for a short trip. And he never he did not come back. For more than a year, Stasha had no
而在斯塔莎看来，他在四处行骗，能骗一个是一个。这一切在斯塔莎18岁时结束了。那一年，即1983年，莱利·谢帕德做了他以前做过很多次的事。他失踪了。他告诉和我母亲——他们已经在一起23年了——说他要去洛杉矶进行一次短途旅行。但当她早晨醒来时，她意识到他带的东西远超一次短途旅行所需。而且他再也没有回来。有一年多的时间，斯塔莎完全
idea where he was. Eventually she found him living about an hour away in Fresno. They reconnected, but everything had changed. She now saw him for exactly who he was. He glamorized the life of being a grifter. He glamorized the life of being a con man. That's what I understand now that he was a con man. It's even hard to say that out loud. He was, though.
不知道他在哪里。最终她发现在大约一小时车程外的弗雷斯诺找到了他。他们重新取得了联系，但一切都变了。她现在看清了他究竟是个什么样的人。他把骗子的生活美化了。他把诈骗犯的生活美化了。我现在才明白他就是一个骗子。甚至很难大声说出这句话。但他确实是。
For years, Stascha felt torn between her distaste for Riley's behavior and her love for the dad who made her smoke rings and took her to the brown derby. By the mid-'80s, Stasha had left Porteville. A few years later, Riley returned to the town and played the role of the old cowboy musician. Stasha mainly stayed in touch by phone as the years passed. One day in 2008, she got a call. Her dad had taken a fall in his home.
多年来，斯塔莎内心充满矛盾，一方面厌恶莱利的所作所为，另一方面又深爱着那个为她吹烟圈、带她去棕色德比餐厅的父亲。到80年代中期，斯塔莎离开了波特维尔。几年后，莱利回到了那个小镇，扮演起了老牛仔音乐家的角色。随着岁月流逝，斯塔莎主要通过电话与他保持联系。2008年的某一天，她接到了一个电话。她父亲在家中摔倒了。
And he ended up in the hospital after being alone on the floor for days. And I called him and he goes, honey, I know I'm gonna die. But he was so sweet. I can't talk about that, but he said he loved me. And that he was proud of me. It was like beautiful. Riley rallied and moved to a nursing home.
由于独自倒在地板上好几天，他最终被送进了医院。我给他打电话，他说：“亲爱的，我知道我要死了。”但他太温柔了。我无法谈论那个，但他说了他爱我。而且他为我感到骄傲。那感觉太美妙了。莱利挺了过来，搬进了一家疗养院。
When Stasha visited, he seemed agitated. And he goes, you don't know what it's like in here. I thought he meant the nursing home because three beds, if I had the TV on, it was loud. I go, what do you, the nursing home? You go, no, you don't, you don't know what it's like in here and here and he was pointing to his head. And I go, what, what are you talking about? He goes, I'm, I'm, I'm flashing back
当斯塔莎去探望他时，他显得很焦虑。他说：“你不知道这里是什么样的。”我以为他说的是疗养院，因为有三张床，如果我把电视打开，声音就会很大。我说：“怎么了，疗养院吗？”他说：“不，你不知道，你不知道这里和这里是什么样的，”他指着自己的脑袋。我说：“什么，你在说什么？”他说：“我正在……”
on all the things I did. And I did some bad things. Stasha tried to comfort him, but in retrospect, she wishes she'd ask a question. What bad things? Tell me about those. What were the bad things? Maybe if you tell me about them, you'll feel better because I'm wondering what all he would have told me.
回想我做过的事。我做了一些坏事。斯塔莎试图安慰他，但事后回想起来，她真希望当时能问一个问题：什么坏事？跟我讲讲那些吧。到底是什么坏事？也许如果你把它们说出来，你会感觉好受些，因为我很想知道他会跟我倾诉些什么。
But he lived for a little bit in the nursing home. That was the last time that I visited him. After Riley died, Stasha wanted the world to remember her father correctly. So she made sure his obituary included not just his real name, but all the pseudonyms he was known to use. Dick Scott, Hickey Free, Clim Hawley, Johnny Rebel, Dickson Hall, Jean Gilmore, Dick Gleason, Paul Lester, Richard Alexander, Albert Riley, Joe Graham, Richard James Hawthorough After Riley died, Stascha had his body cremated.
但他又在疗养院里活了一小段时间。那是我最后一次去探望他。莱利死后，斯塔莎希望世人能正确地记住她的父亲。因此她确保他的讣告中不仅列出了他的真名，还列出了他曾使用过的所有化名：迪克·斯科特（Dick Scott）、希基·弗里（Hickey Free）、克利姆·霍利（Clim Hawley）、强尼·里贝尔（Johnny Rebel）、迪克森·霍尔（Dickson Hall）、吉恩·吉尔摩（Jean Gilmore）、迪克·格利森（Dick Gleason）、保罗·莱斯特（Paul Lester）、理查德·亚历山大（Richard Alexander）、阿尔伯特·莱利（Albert Riley）、乔·格雷厄姆（Joe Graham）、理查德·詹姆斯·霍索恩（Richard James Hawthorough）。莱利死后，斯塔莎将他的遗体火化了。
For a long time, she carried his ashes around with her. She'd scatter a handful here or there, which seemed fitting for a drifter. I never can forget, on that day when first we met, I was never nearer heaven in my life. There wasn't much in the Raleigh Shepherd estate. Stasha packed up some of his letters, a cookbook he'd written for her, and various other papers. But his life's work, the Encyclopedia he'd been toiling over all those years, he'd left that to someone else. And in here, we find row upon row of collection boxes on the shelf. By the time I got to the basement of the Library of Congress, I figured I knew everything I needed to know about Riley Shepard. He was a crook, a con man, a bad husband, an unreliable father.
很长一段时间里，她一直随身带着他的骨灰。她会在这里或那里撒上一把，对于一个流浪汉来说，这似乎很合适。我永远不会忘记，在我们初次相遇的那一天，我从未离天堂如此之近过。莱利·谢帕德的遗产并不多。斯塔莎收拾了他的一些信件、一本他为她写的食谱以及其他各种文件。但他一生的心血——那部他多年来一直在苦心钻研的百科全书，他把它留给了别人。在这里，我们看到书架上一排又一排的藏品盒。当我到达国会图书馆的地下室时，我以为我已经知道了关于莱利·谢帕德的一切。他是个骗子、诈骗犯、糟糕的丈夫、不负责任的父亲。
So as folkloreist Steve Winnick pulls out the Richard Riley Shepherd collection from the stacks, I'm not holding my breath. Nobody's really used this collection very much, so it's simply, you know, been there waiting for you, really. Up in his office, Hagrid, aka folkloreistlorist Steve Winick, spreads out the papers from the Richard Riley Shepard collection on a table. He picks up a letter. The date of this letter is September 7, 1976.
因此，当民俗学者史蒂夫·维尼克从书库中抽出理查德·莱利·谢帕德的藏品时，我并没有屏住呼吸。基本上没有人用过这个藏品，所以它只是，你知道的，一直在那儿等着你，真的。在他的办公室里，海格——也就是民俗学家史蒂夫·维尼克——把理查德·莱利·谢帕德藏品中的文件摊在桌子上。他拿起一封信。这封信的日期是1976年9月7日。
More than four decades ago, Riley wrote this letter to the registrar of copyrights. Stascha was 11 years old. So he was working on things. He was working on, I didn't know what. In the letter, Riley asks for the forms he'll need to copyright and encyclopedia. He adds a long post script. He says, perhaps someone in the Library of Congress
四十多年前，莱利写了这封信给版权登记局。当时斯塔莎11岁。所以他一直在忙着做事情。他在忙着，我不知道是什么。在这封信中，莱利索取为百科全书申请版权所需的表格。他加上了一个很长的附言。他说，也许国会图书馆的某个人
would be interested in the following. Over the past 16 years, I alphabetically indexed more than 43,000 titles of songs, including published versions and variants in English, French, Spanish, etc., all of which have enjoyed a folk-type tradition within the borders of the United States and Canada. All the titles he continues have been alphabetically cross-indexed and cross-referenced with the titles of books they appeared in, along with the editors and publishers. Each reference is clearly coded so that practically every folk song relative to the United States, plus all its known versions and variants, can be easily located.
会对以下内容感兴趣。在过去的16年中，我以字母顺序为43,000多个歌曲标题编制了索引，包括在美国和加拿大境内流传过的英语、法语、西班牙语等的已出版版本和变体。他接着说，所有的标题都已按字母顺序进行了交叉索引，并与它们出现的书籍标题以及编辑和出版商进行了交叉引用。每个参考都经过清晰编码，以便实际上与美国有关的每一首民歌及其所有已知的版本和变体都可以轻松找到。
You may be interested to learn that the 43,000 titles are clearly the outgrowth of only 4,000 songs, texts and tunes. He ends the letter this way. I know only one thing. I am the only person in the world with this amount of cross-index, cross-referenced musical material. Unfortunately, I do not own or have access to a computer in which to feed the information. Perhaps the Library of Congress can offer suggestions? Perhaps the Library of Congress can offer suggestions.
你可能会感兴趣地了解到，这43,000个标题显然仅仅是由4,000首歌曲、歌词和曲调演变而来的。他是这样结束这封信的。我只知道一件事。我是世界上唯一拥有如此大量交叉索引、交叉引用音乐资料的人。不幸的是，我没有或无法使用计算机来输入这些信息。也许国会图书馆能提供一些建议？也许国会图书馆能提供一些建议？
Riley wanted to get his encyclopedia to a wider audience. The chief archivist at the time wrote back and offered the names of potential publishers. He also said he'd like to see some of Riley's work, so Riley sent in the samples that the library now holds. In a follow-up letter, Riley explained how his indexing system worked. Each title is followed by the first line or lines of the song and or versions thereof, and this by the source, example. Gouce hangs high, the Civil War Ballad. It deals with Lee's invasion of Pennsylvania and the battle of
莱利想让他的百科全书面向更广泛的受众。当时的首席档案管理员回信并提供了潜在出版商的名字。他还说他想看看莱利的一些作品，于是莱利寄去了图书馆现在持有的样本。在随后的信中，莱利解释了他的索引系统是如何运作的。每个标题后面都跟着歌曲的第一行或几行歌词和/或其版本，然后是出处，例如：《高斯高高悬挂》（Gouce hangs high），南北战争民谣。它讲述了李将军入侵宾夕法尼亚和战役的
Gettysburg. As Steve Winick sifts through the materials, he slowly grasps the enormity of the project. So he's got 43,000 individual sheets or two sheets of paper however long it takes, that he's got to then sort into 4,000 categories. And then in addition to that, he asked to cross-reference each of those with all of the places that they've been published. So there's an enormous number of cross references within this book that he had to do by hand without the ability to electronically associate
葛底斯堡。当史蒂夫·维尼克仔细翻阅这些材料时，他慢慢意识到了这个项目的庞大程度。所以他有43,000张单独的纸页或两页纸——不管需要多少页——他必须把它们分类到4,000个类别中。然后除此之外，他还必须将其中每一个与它们发表过的所有地方进行交叉引用。因此，这本书中存在着数量惊人的交叉引用，而这一切都是他手工完成的，当时并不具备以电子方式关联
one item with another. the ability to electronically associate one item with another. What Riley Shepard had been working on since 1960 was a monumental accounting of some 200 years of American folk music. It involved a search of nearly every available documentary source. Riley had obtained rare books at great expense, including many that were out of print. He had collated thousands of songs and organized them according to their provenance, discovering common roots and pathways that linked different musical traditions together. Since he did not have a computer, almost no one did at the time, he did everything by hand, cross-referencing song lyrics and musical notations and historical
一个项目与另一个项目的功能。自1960年以来，莱利·谢帕德一直致力于一项对大约200年美国民间音乐的宏大盘点。这涉及查阅几乎所有可用的文献资料。莱利不惜重金搜集了珍稀书籍，包括许多绝版书。他整理了数千首歌曲，并根据它们的出处进行编排，发现了将不同音乐传统联系在一起的共同根源和途径。由于他没有电脑（当时几乎没有人有），他所有的事情都是亲力亲为，将歌词、乐谱和历史
footnotes. Crazy as it sounds, the entire system lived largely inside his own head. By the point he wrote to the Library of Congress, he had spent nearly two decades trying to put down on paper what was in his head, even as his life fell apart around him, and many of his closest friends and relatives came to think of him as a crook. At the time, as far as I know, no one had attempted something this ambitious in terms of indexing all the songs in America. Riley Shepard, a man with a fifth grade education, an occasional writer of porn, a con man and hustler, had attempted to create something that would require years of effort
脚注进行交叉引用。听起来很疯狂，整个系统基本上都存在于他自己的脑海中。当他写信给国会图书馆时，他已经花了将近二十年的时间试图把自己脑海中的东西落实在纸上，尽管他的生活在他周围分崩离析，他的许多挚友和亲戚也开始认为他是个骗子。当时，据我所知，在对美国所有歌曲进行索引方面，还没有人尝试过如此宏大的工程。莱利·谢帕德，一个只有五年级学历、偶尔写写色情小说的骗子和投机者，却试图创造出这样一个项目：它需要由一小支博士档案管理员团队和一小群研究人员耗费多年的努力才能完成。我认为，这一尝试本身其实是美国民间歌曲学术史上的一个重要事实。而且这实际上几乎没有人知道。如果不是你引起我的注意，我也不会知道。而且，你知道的，我已经研究这个好多年了。我请史蒂夫挑选一首歌曲，并解释莱利是如何对其进行分类的。于是他打开了第三卷，手指顺着满是打字机输入条目的页面往下滑。
by a team of PhD archivists and a small army of researchers. The fact of the attempt, I think, is actually a significant fact in the history of folk song scholarship in the United States. And it's actually something almost nobody knows about. I wouldn't know about it if you hadn't brought it to my attention. And, you know, I've studied this for quite a number of years. I asked Steve to choose a song and explain how Riley had classified it. So he opened Volume 3, ran his finger down pages filled with typerate entries.
所以，我翻到一个我非常熟悉的。这是《霍洛韦·乔》（Holloway Joe），这是一首船歌，上面写着，这是一首短拖或短程船歌。它采自英国水手并被美国化，这意味着文本中的政治参考被消除了。美国水手更喜欢专注于女孩。例如，英国水手唱道：
So, I'll go to one that I'm quite familiar with. This is Holloway Joe, which is a C-shanty, and it says, this is a short drag or short haul shanty. It was taken from British sailors and Americanized, which means political references were eliminated from the text. American sailors preferred to concentrate on girls. For example, the British sailors saying,
路易斯是革命前的法国国王，但路易斯被砍了头，这破坏了他的体制。美国水手有更重要的事要唱，于是把歌词改成：我曾有个德国女孩，但她又胖又懒，后来我有个爱尔兰女孩，她把我快逼疯了。这首船歌可追溯到18世纪下半叶，尽管在英国和美国，它可追溯到1812年战争之后的几年。
Louis was the king of France before the revolution, but Louis got his head cut off, which spoiled his constitution. American sailors had more important things to sing about, and changed the words to, once I had a German girl, but she was fat and lazy, then I had an Irish girl, she damn near drove me crazy. The shanti dates back to around the second half of the 18th century, though only in England in the USA it dates back to the years following the word 1812.
有关其他英国和美国版本，请参见下面列出的作品。然后他列出了这首歌出现的大量书籍清单。而且他实际上也为你提供了这首歌的乐谱。对于他所做的许多歌曲，是的，他确实也为《霍洛韦·乔》提供了乐谱。这首歌的曲调是怎么样的？你还记得吗？
For other English and American versions, see the works listed below. And then he gives a long list of books in which this song appears. And he actually gives you the music for the song as well. And for many of the songs he does, yes, he does have music for Hallow H.O. as well. How does the tune of this song go? Do you remember it?
当我还是个小男孩时，我母亲告诉我的一切，哦，乔，一直以来，一直以来。现在，如果我不亲吻女孩，我的嘴唇就会发霉，哦，乔，一直以来，一直以来。我不得不说，厉害的地方在于你合上书就能唱出来。这也是全记在你的脑子里吧。是的。
When I was a little boy, it's all my mother told me, Way all the way, all the way, Joe. Now, if I didn't kiss the girls, my lips would all grow moldy away, All the way, all the way, Joe. I have to say the impressive thing is you closed the book and you did that. This was all in your head, too. It was.
当你合上书就能唱出来。这也是全记在你的脑子里吧。是的。1979年，在他第一封信的三年后，莱利再次与国会图书馆取得了联系。他说他一直没能找到出版商。于是他写道：尊敬的希克森先生，如果您不记得了，
as you close the book and you did that. This was all in your hand, too. It was. In 1979, three years after his first letter, Riley got in touch again with the Library of Congress. He said he'd been unable to find a publisher. And so he writes, Dear Mr. Hickerson, in case you don't remember,
我随信附上了您于1977年7月8日写给我的信的复印件。首先，我要感谢您提供的建议以及可能出版商的地址。我跟进了，但没有资金可用于像我这样的工作，尽管他们对我的工作成果很感兴趣，并且会很感激能有一份“民歌搜寻者与索引”（folk song finder and index）。这是一部卷帙浩繁的作品，所以我能理解出版商不愿意承担出版费用的顾虑。所以现在我又来找您了。
I have enclosed a photocopy of your letter to me dated July 8, 1977. First, I want to thank you for your suggestions and the addresses of possible publishers. I followed up, no funds are available for a work such as mine, though they are interested in what I have done and would appreciate a copy of the folk song finder and index. It is a voluminous work, so I can understand the reluctance of a publisher to undertake the expense of its publication. So here I am, back to you again.
这是一个绝望之举。如果您真的有意让图书馆与我达成某种协议，我已经准备好推进了。我的问题是这样的，在给我的经济报酬方面，我不知道该要求多少。我确实知道，我不能要求弥补我所花费的时间、工作和金钱，但我希望能收回至少一部分我自己的支出，哪怕不是对我工作和时间的报酬。事实上，我必须收回我所花费的一些钱，因为我已经签下了加利福尼亚州波特维尔的一个小农场和房子的租约，预计在大约六周内搬到那里。正如乡村音乐界所说的那样，我已经身无分文了。莱利从未得到他所寻求的东西。
It was an act of desperation. If you were our serious about the library reaching some agreement with me, I am ready to proceed. My problem is this, I don't know what to ask for in terms of financial remuneration to myself. I do know that I cannot ask as much as I have spent in terms of time, work, and money, but I would like to recoup at least some of my own expenditures, if not payment, for my work and time. In fact, I must recoup some of what I have spent because I have already signed a lease on a small farm and house in Porterville, California, and expect to move there in approximately six weeks. As I am, as they say in the country music field, flat busted. Riley never got what he was seeking.
他所要求的是一大笔资金投入，我认为图书馆当时实在承担不起，或者无法……你知道的，为那个项目拨出这笔款项。因为正如他在信中所说，除了这些卷宗之外，这本书还有另外54卷。另外54卷。经过近二十年苦心孤诣的工作，最终迎来了极大的侮辱。拒绝。
What he was asking was a significant outlay of money that I just think the library couldn't afford at the time or couldn't, you know, a portion to that project. Because as he says in the correspondence, in addition to these volumes, there are 54 other volumes of this book. 54 other volumes. After nearly two decades of painstaking work came the final indignity. Rejection.
是的，我想你可以说他是从出版书籍（即纸质书）向电脑文档转变过程中的早期牺牲品。而且他意识到了这一点。我的意思是，因为他谈到了如果能把这些输入电脑该有多好。你会说莱利·谢帕德是个天才吗？我想他是个天才。我的意思是，看到他在这个项目上所做的工作量，真的非常令人印象深刻。而且他身上也具备那种你必须拥有的疯狂毅力。所以你知道，那是另一种天才。
Yeah, I think he was an early casualty, you might say, of the switch from published books that is paper books to computer documentation. And he's aware of this. I mean, because he talks about how it would be great if he could put this into a computer. Would you say that Rhinoshepa was a genius? He was a genius I think. I mean it's very impressive to see the amount of work that he did on this. And he also had that sort of crazy perseverance that you have to have. So you know that's a whole other kind of genius.
这里有一个真正令人惊叹的部分。在接下来的25年里，莱利继续致力于这部百科全书的编写。我的意思是，事实上，既然他本应在1979年将此寄给图书馆，那么后来又有更多版本的传统歌曲被出版了。因此，如果他试图保持这本书的完整性，他就必须年复一年地不断更新它。
Here is a really amazing part. Riley continued to work on the Encyclopedia for the next 25 years. I mean, it is the case that since he would have sent this to the library in 1979, a lot more versions of traditional songs were published. So if he were trying to keep this book complete, he would have to continue to update it year after year.
有趣的一件事情是，我不确定他的家人是否真正完全理解他所做的事情。当我与他的女儿斯塔莎交谈时，她只觉得她爸爸只是有点痴迷于这个似乎毫无进展、似乎永无止境、只是无限膨胀的项目。而且你知道，多年来，她实际上也接到过那些他曾向其借钱和拿钱的人的电话。而且，你知道的，她对她父亲的印象并不是一个非常积极的印象。从某种程度上说，与你交谈后，我对这个男人有了不同的看法。
One of the interesting things is I'm not sure his family actually fully understands what he has done. When I spoke with his daughter, Starsha, she just thought her dad was sort of obsessed with this project that never seemed to go anywhere, that never seemed to end, that just grew infinitely. And you know, over the years, she, in fact, heard from people whom he had borrowed money from and taken money from. And, you know, her impression of her dad is not a very positive impression. And in some way, speaking with you, I get a different picture of this man.
有趣的一点是，我不确定他的家人是否真正完全理解他所做的事情。当我与他的女儿斯塔莎交谈时，她只是觉得她父亲有点沉迷于这个似乎永远不会有进展、似乎永远不会结束、而且只是无限膨胀的项目。你知道的，多年来，她实际上听到过那些他曾向其借钱和拿钱的人的抱怨。而且，你知道的，她对她父亲的印象并不是一个非常积极的印象。从某种程度上说，与你交谈后，我对这个男人有了不同的看法。
Well, I think that all scholars, and particularly folk song scholars, have something of the Riley Shepherd in them. We would like to spend all our time and all our life immersed in the texts and tunes of folk songs. We just can't manage it because we have lives. And so the amount of yourself that you're willing to give to that might vary for different people, but we certainly have sympathy for someone who gave so much of himself to it.
嗯，我认为所有的学者，特别是民歌学者，身上都有点莱利·谢泼德的影子。我们愿意把所有的时间和生命都沉浸在民歌的歌词和曲调中。我们只是无法做到，因为我们还要生活。因此，你愿意为之付出多少精力因人而异，但我们绝对同情那些为此奉献了那么多心血的人。
I don't know if you're familiar with the anthropologist Arnold Van Henepp. He's the person who popularized the term rights of passage. And Van Hennep wrote a piece called The Research Project, or Folkler Without End. And it was about a person who decided to write the definitive work on the evil eye. And he went to his Carol in the library, and he began getting all the books about the evil eye, and he compiled all of the references that he could find.
我不知道你是否熟悉人类学家阿诺德·范·热内普。他是普及“过渡仪式”这个术语的人。范·热内普写过一篇名为《研究项目》或《无休止的民俗学》的文章。文章讲述了一个决定撰写关于“邪眼”的权威著作的人。他去了图书馆的研究室，开始收集所有关于邪眼的图书，并尽可能地汇编了所有的参考文献。
And he took it to his advisor and his advisor says, this is a great start, but there's still other cultures. And there's ancient Greek and Roman sources that you should look at. And so he goes back and he works on those. And this continues for years and years. And eventually this man dies at his Carol in the library. And nobody quite remembers what he was doing there.
他把资料拿给导师看，导师说，这是一个很好的开始，但还有其他文化，还有你应该了解的古希腊和古罗马资料。于是他回去继续研究。这种情况持续了好几年。最终，这个人死在了图书馆的研究室里，也没人太记得他在那里究竟在做什么。
And that's kind of the impression that you get of Riley Shepherd. But it turned out there was someone next to Riley in his final days as he labored away in his carol. Before he collapsed and was sent to the hospital, Riley was living in a small house on D Street in Porteville. He was in rough shape. I thought, you know, he's a little bit disheveled. But Steve Enslyn, a Porteville native, says once you got to know Riley, he grew on you. It was Steve's father, Ted, who really knew Riley.
这正是你对莱利·谢泼德的印象。但事实证明，在莱利生命中的最后几天里，当他在研究室里辛苦劳作时，他身边还有一个人。在晕倒并被送往医院之前，莱利住在波特维尔D街的一栋小房子里。他的情况很糟糕。我想，你知道的，他有点不修边幅。但波特维尔本地人史蒂夫·恩斯林说，一旦你了解了莱利，你就会渐渐喜欢上他。是史蒂夫的父亲特德真正了解莱利。
Ted was a retired insurance agent and former Portaville mayor. Steve says his dad and Riley bonded over a shared love of music. They would just sit and listen to country western music, the old country western music, not the new stuff. They were friends. They were also business partners. They wrote songs together, they recorded a few songs together. Mainly though, they worked on Riley's encyclopedia. Ted saw the genius in it. They spent hours and hours and hours just collecting all the material and then categorizing it.
特德是一名退休的保险代理人和波特维尔前市长。史蒂夫说，他的父亲和莱利因为对音乐的共同热爱而结下了不解之缘。他们就那样坐着听乡村西部音乐，老派的乡村西部音乐，而不是新潮的音乐。他们是朋友，也是商业伙伴。他们一起写歌，一起录制了几首歌。不过，他们主要还是在为莱利的百科全书工作。特德从中看到了天才。他们花了数不清的时间收集所有的资料，然后进行分类。
Steve says Riley was still consumed by the project. Well, he had music spread all over. I mean, he had tables and chairs and floor and everything, and he had had this music spread out, and he was trying to get it in some sort of a chronological order, and by the artist, he was trying to get the artist with the song and he would have the song and then he would have the artist. And so he would try to cross reference all of those. So it was a labor of love, I'll tell you that, but he was, he just, no, I haven't got time for that.
史蒂夫说，莱利依然全神贯注于这个项目。嗯，他的音乐到处都是。我的意思是，他有桌子、椅子、地板，什么都有，他把这些音乐铺开，他试图按某种时间顺序列出它们，按艺术家分类，他试图把艺术家和歌曲对应起来，他有歌曲，然后有艺术家。所以他试图将所有这些进行交叉引用。所以这是一项爱的劳作，我可以告诉你，但他就是……不，我没时间做那个。
I don't want to eat. I just, I got to get this done. I, this is, this is important. And so he would just, he was funny. Stephen's father both felt they were in the presence of an extraordinary human being. Riley Shepard was, was a master. He, he did a lot of things, but he was quite a, quite a, quite a master. did a lot of things, but he was quite a master. Steve's father willingly gave his time to the project, and he gave money, plenty of it. Steve says after Riley died, Stashe got in touch. She was concerned that her dad had conned his dad, but Steve says the money wasn't important. The money doesn't mean anything as far as I saw the enjoyment that it brought to my dad. Riley left his life's work, the encyclopedia of folk music, to his friend Ted Inselin.
我不想吃东西。我只是，我必须把这个做完。我，这，这很重要。所以他只是……他很有趣。史蒂夫的父亲都觉得他们正身处一个非凡的人身边。莱利·谢泼德是一位……是一位大师。他做过很多事，但他确实是一位……一位……一位大师。史蒂夫的父亲心甘情愿地为这个项目奉献了时间，还给了钱，而且数额巨大。史蒂夫说，莱利死后，斯塔莎联系了他们。她担心莱利的父亲骗了她父亲，但史蒂夫说钱并不重要。只要看到它给我父亲带来的快乐，钱就没有任何意义。莱利把他一生的心血——民歌百科全书——留给了他的朋友特德·恩斯林。
They were 40 boxes. Ted stored them in his old insurance office, and that's where they sat for years. I kept asking dad, you know, what are you going to do with these dad? What are you going to do with these? And he says, he says, there worth a lot of money. And I said, well, I know about what are you going to do with them. Ted never did anything with them. He was old and suffering from dementia. Instead, he just relived his friendship with Riley.
那里有40箱。特德把它们存在他旧的保险办公室里，它们就在那里放了好几年。我一直问爸爸，你知道的，爸爸，你打算拿这些怎么办？你打算拿这些怎么办？他说，他说，这些值很多钱。我说，好吧，我知道，但你打算怎么处理它们。特德从来没有对它们做过什么。他老了，患有痴呆症。相反，他只是在不断重温他与莱利的友谊。
After Riley died, my dad had a little record player in his office, and he would put on a lot of Riley's country-western music. It was fun while it lasted, but it didn't last too long. You've left me for somebody new. And he just enjoyed Riley and enjoyed his friendship. But darling, I still believe in you. Won't you please come back and know I love you to the end? When Ted Enselin died, Steve gave the encyclopedia to another man in town who happened to be a country music songwriter. Steve says he was told the pages of carefully indexed entries were eventually split up.
莱利死后，我爸爸在他的办公室里放了一个小唱片机，他会放很多莱利的乡村西部音乐。曾经的美好时光虽然持续了，但并没有持续太久。你为了新欢抛弃了我。他只是在享受莱利，享受他们的友谊。但亲爱的，我依然相信你。你难道不能回来，知道我爱你直到永远吗？特德·恩斯林去世后，史蒂夫把这部百科全书送给了镇上的另一个人，那人碰巧是一位乡村音乐词曲作者。史蒂夫说，据他所知，那些精心索引条目的书页最终被拆散了。
Some were shipped off to Nashville and some to the Buckowen's Museum in Baker's Field, California. Other copies are also floating around. Not long ago, Stascha says a couple who'd invested in Riles and Cyclopedia got in touch. They were willing to sell their copy to her for $500. She bought it. She says, it's huge. Well, it's weird to see the whole thing and how much work he actually put into it because after I realized how much my father fabricated on various things from, you know,
有些被运到了纳什维尔，有些被运到了加利福尼亚州贝克斯菲尔德的巴克·欧文斯博物馆。还有其他副本在到处流传。不久前，斯塔莎说，一对曾投资莱利百科全书的夫妇联系了她。他们愿意以500美元的价格把他们的副本卖给她。她买下了。她说，这太庞大了。嗯，看到整个东西以及他实际上投入了多少工作感觉很奇怪，因为在我意识到我父亲在各种事情上编造了多少谎言之后，从，你知道的，
he just was a compulsive liar. Sometimes he would make things up and I couldn't figure out why, why did you lie about that? Why didn't you brag about the songs you actually wrote? Why did you say you wrote blue Christmas or whatever? And so I became kind of jaded and I began to think that maybe the whole project to the Encyclopedia was not even worth thinking about it all. I loved my dad but I kind of rolled my eyes whenever I thought about these projects,
他简直是个强迫性说谎者。有时他会凭空捏造事情，而我却弄不明白为什么，你为什么要为那个说谎？你为什么不吹嘘你真正创作的那些歌曲呢？你为什么说你写了《蓝色圣诞节》之类的歌？因此我变得有点厌倦，我开始认为百科全书的整个项目甚至都不值得去考虑。我爱我爸爸，但每当我想到这些项目时，我总是忍不住翻白眼，
because so much, so much smoke and mirrors around it. And the conversation near the end of his life, the one recorded by music historian Kevin Koffee, Raleigh Sheper doesn't sound bitter or frustrated. He sounds like a man still doing what he loves, honoring the music he had learned as a boy, trying to preserve it. In fact, he told Kevin, there were still plenty of songs and music that were left in him. I'm writing one now. I've got a call the over you get. The more it's going to cost you to do the order you get. The more it's going to cost you to do the thing you did when you were young.
因为周围有太多的虚假宣传。在他生命接近尾声时的那场对话中——由音乐历史学家凯文·科菲录制的对话中听起来，雷利·谢泼德并不显得痛苦或沮丧。他听起来像是一个仍在做自己热爱的事情的人，在向他儿时学到的音乐致敬，并试图将其保存下来。事实上，他告诉凯文，他体内依然有很多歌曲和音乐。我现在正在写一首歌。我得去克服它。你越老，为了做你年轻时做过的事，你要付出的代价就越多。
When an old man's in love, he just thinks he's in love. He's not cooking with gas, he's just warming it over. It's a good song, right? Songs and novels are filled with stories about people with great obsessions. We have strong opinions about such people. When they succeed, when they produce the Taj Mahal or Hamlet or the iPhone, we hail the obsessions that build the monuments of this world. When we count the collateral damage that people with obsessions leave in their wake, especially when those obsessions only produce the unreadable tom on the evil eye or an unpublishable encyclopedia on folk music.
当一个老头陷入爱河时，他只是觉得自己陷入爱河了。他并不是在动真格，他只是在重温旧梦。这是一首好歌，对吧？歌曲和小说里充满了关于有着巨大执念的人的故事。我们对这样的人有着强烈的看法。当他们成功时，当他们建造了泰姬陵、写出了《哈姆雷特》或是发明了iPhone时，我们为建立这个世界丰碑的执念欢呼。当我们计算那些有执念的人在身后留下的附带损害时——尤其是当这些执念只催生出关于邪眼的不可读皇皇巨著，或是关于民歌的无法出版的百科全书时，
Obsessions start to look like folly. Trouble is, you usually do not know whether an obsession is a great quest or a great folly until it's over. This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt and Parth Shah and edited by Tara Boyle. Special thanks to Ashley Messenger. Our team includes Rina Cohen, Laura Quarell, Thomas Liu and Kimela Vargas Restrepo. Engineering support from Patrick Boyd and Andy Huthar. Our unsung heroes today are Hugh Williams and Radio Orkney in Scotland. One of the difficulties we faced with this episode was finding audio of Riley Shepard's voice.
执念开始看起来像是一种愚蠢。问题是，通常在你结束之前，你并不知道一个执念究竟是一场伟大的探索还是一场巨大的愚蠢。本周的节目由珍妮·施密特和帕思·沙制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。特别感谢阿什利·梅森杰。我们的团队包括丽娜·科恩、劳拉·夸雷尔、托马斯·刘和基梅拉·瓦尔加斯·雷斯特雷波。工程支持来自帕特里克·博伊尔和安迪·胡萨尔。我们今天的无名英雄是休·威廉姆斯和苏格兰奥克尼电台。我们在制作这一期节目时遇到的困难之一是寻找莱利·谢泼德的声音音频。
Happily, we discovered that music historian Kevin Coffey still had tape of the interview he did with Riley. Our next challenge was connecting with Kevin, who lives in the Orkney Islands in Scotland. Hugh Williams and his team at Radio Orkney were able to help us record an interview. We are so grateful for their help. For more hidden brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter to see a slight show of photos of Riley Shepard visit our website npr.org slash Hidden Brain. If this episode spoke to you, please take a moment to share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
令人高兴的是，我们发现音乐历史学家凯文·科菲仍然保留着他与莱利采访的磁带。我们的下一个挑战是联系住在苏格兰奥克尼群岛的凯文。休·威廉姆斯和他在奥克尼电台的团队帮助我们录制了一段采访。我们非常感谢他们的帮助。想要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们，若想查看莱利·谢泼德的照片幻灯片，请访问我们的网站 npr.org slash Hidden Brain。如果这一期节目触动了你，请花一点时间把它分享给朋友。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。